is it harder to be a man or harder to be
a woman a man for sure yeah and you're
saying a man
you're saying a man a woman and you're
saying man a man dude i totally disagree
with you guys we're gonna tell you why
okay i'll tell you why
what you said i think it's hard to be a
woman no i think women have to also like
they have to swallow certain things that
they don't like like certain like if
you're with a successful man
you know a lot of the time they but
that's not true again that's why you
allow what you think success is but
success is not having multiple women
like i'm not
again
right but women women have kids women
have uh that's a beautiful thing to have
right but the thing is let me explain
that let me explain why i'll open this
up okay here we go all three of you said
men and and apparently it didn't italian
and i'll tell you why
it's because clarity matters
to be a man
it's crystal f and clear what your job
is
get out there compete in the marketplace
make some money bring value don't be a
piece of [ __ ] don't be lazy
like have resources get your act
together look good right clarity women
go be a housewife no go be a strong
independent woman no go have kids no
kind of have a part-time job be
passionate about something no listen to
your man which one is it
women don't have clarity and that is the
biggest problem men have crystal clear
clarity what the objective is if you're
a man and you don't get what you need to
do you're a loser
okay and you're complaining in your
mom's basement if you're a woman and
you're jorita and you did kind of
contradict yourself because i'll tell
you why
super impressed i'm gonna i'm gonna
bring crypto to albania i'm gonna do all
this guys i'm doing it i'm not i know
you're doing it respect exactly and then
after doing all that i'm going to shut
up and listen to my man that's not what
i did say no ideas but guys are trying
to twist but let me finish my point
we'll go to you the point is this
a guy it's
run straight just keep running you might
have to stop on the side of the road
grab some water but keep running a woman
it's run stop have a baby feed the baby
nope get back a career get back in the
car hold on we got a door dash nope you
got to cook which one should i work now
but there's
there's not a lot of clarity with being
a woman i'm empathizing with you don't
argue with me
i'm trying to help you here but for for
me the intention of this show because
again a majority of our viewers are men
is so you can be more like matt you can
be more like derek you can be like more
like about your boy sauce figure it out
your life your purpose and life and run
towards it it's a lot harder to do that
if you're a woman do you disagree women
have more options they can be successful
they could be housewives they can be
more options you know they could be
let's go around the table here that's
how you go yeah yeah i mean i agree with
you adam i think women because
especially today like you can find any
type of woman you can find a housewife
you can find a successful woman you can
find like really whatever you're looking
for for men
like
successful
in shape you know what i mean provide
value leader you know like things like
there's just one thing they're going
towards like you said i feel like women
because we have so many options
um we can get lost and i think if you
get too lost you have a life that you
regret don't get lost in the socks
unless it's on the surface
that's the pot
i don't think vladimir clear
i don't think they are i think they're
uh they're they're also searching i
think we're in an era right now where
this these economic times the times of
our country has caused and create a lot
of weak men out there yeah they're not
providing they're not standing up for
for values and principles they're not
standing up as the backbone of their
family and children things that happen
to our kids where mom and dad or dad
should be standing up and say hey what's
going on here and yet they're deferring
to their wives to go down to the schools
to get it done it actually should be the
father going down to get it done listen
there's a saying there it says when the
man stands up the boy sits down
i think too many boys are standing up
today because they're not clear about
what they're doing and what their their
roles are i think there's a there's a
fogginess about what a man today is in
society good friend of mine
rafa khanda he's a
retired cop right around here he runs a
company called man of war he's spoken at
his conference a couple of times
i can't tell you how many men there are
just confused about what their roles in
in a relationship
in a relationship or in life and well
yeah in life and with their money their
finances you know and i'll tell you this
there's days that i feel as a dad as an
entrepreneur as a
uh as a husband i'm not
like a few days ago i was like every
everything i was dealing with in terms
of decisions i had an l i lost with my
wife i lost with my kids i lost with the
business a lot of bad investment deals
what a wonderful day
but i still had to say
you know i'm still a man here's another
key element
mother's day and father's day
who celebrates it more
mother's day of course mother's day you
can't get you can't even get a seat of
course you can't even you can't even
feel you got a handshake on father's day
father's day yo you're going to
restaurants thank you father
[Laughter]
mother's day you know you got to wait
three hours to get to school if i was
that yeah come on we have a seat right
here for you in the restaurant because i
think society's assumed that men know
what they're doing and what their roles
are so right so how can men get more
clarity bio who wants to answer that
well i wanted to say first um how can
men get more clarity a woman response
a woman cannot
be clear until she has a man
directing her yeah really so this is why
most females are confused and they're
trying to seek everything else
but from outside sources why because of
money but if you're not clear how do you
pick the right man but that's your
problem you have to find yourself
that's the main thing that's the first
thing that you have to figure out before
you pick your partner to lead you but
that's not why females have it harder
it's because females are making it
harder on themselves who is telling a
female to be confused enough follow men
while their father clearly because they
were not raised by a good father and
then now they do not interest they
cannot choose a good man i mean you have
society saying like you know well then
you'll be successful
if you listen to society you're weak
that's all it is you're just not being
actually the designer of your life
you're just wanting to be a follower and
that's okay this world is not for
everyone somebody will follow somebody
will lead
but
then don't blame the other people like
it's your fault and how men can find
clarity just uh yeah out onto how men
can find clearly fortunately meditation
yeah we're in times where people could
just tune in people could tune in listen
to discussions like this people can you
know where information is is flying is
is quick we have access we have damn
near unlimited access to it so you know
uh by my brother o'neil he mentioned
not all lions are going to survive in
the wild not all lions are going to eat
not all lions are going to be are going
to breed
and and that falls in the same way as us
as human beings not all men are going to
a have have a family start a family be
able to have kids uh be able to upscale
grow and whatnot um
adding on on why i believe that men have
it harder because men have an unseen
burden on
on what it is to be a man
in a sense
a lot of times when men when we take l's
we take l's hard we take else's heart
it's probably wow wow
privately and you're not even allowed to
be emotional right or you're not even
allowed to express yourself because
you're a man and you have to like put
your medson up so um i mean i would say
that's what that's what makes us men
that's what that's because
i believe that we grow from adversity we
grow from adversity we grow from taking
falls scraping our knee what not
it takes me back to the time when i was
a kid riding the bike take my training
wheels off
and then i scraped my knee
two things i could have did
went inside cried to my mom i don't want
this bike no more or i could have been
like i want to ride my bike i want to
ride my bike i see my friends riding
around my bike and whatnot and that's
what that's what grew me and that's what
made us that's what makes men tougher
from a small scrape off the bike from
yeah hey this chick this chick dumped me
either or i got to get i got i still got
things to get work done five ten times
get up eleven mm-hmm that's what's
making me think that's why men love
sports so much more than women yeah
because they're cheering for a team
rooting for a team because they got
clarity that their team's gotta win they
gotta score the touchdown they gotta
score these points and men love seeing
other men
accomplish that goal because they live
vicariously through that camaraderie i
would say camaraderie just like the
military yeah just like the military
yeah because who's got deeper
camaraderie uh even in the military male
or female in the military
who's got more who's more of a fanatical
disposition when it comes to sports male
or female male 1
because watches females with sports no
no
by the way
after this i have tickets for the wnba
game after this if you guys are
interested name five wnba stars i i
don't well all i know is lebron nba
right right yeah not w w nba star sorry
anyway i no you're right brittany
greiner who's trapped in uh
i introduced because
i don't know anything okay so let's get
back to this part of clarity because i
still think that
okay how about this
men may lack clarity but we know what
they need to do right yeah okay
get a career
make some freaking money add value
get in shape look like derek if you can
or matt i don't know
and you know
have some frame as they call it right
what rollo talks about it's clear what
you got to do we just did this at the
cme make muscles make money have friend
boom you know what you got to do it's
still very unclear what a woman has to
do
follow a guy a man this is what i'm
trying to tell you it's so easy
but let me circle back to this
please let her finish that but if you
say follow a man and your man's telling
you quit what you're doing work i want
you to be a housewife that's okay but
but you're funny that's okay you follow
your man because at some times your man
knows best if my man tells me will tell
me like how he will provide for
everything else how he will fulfill what
i have then that is okay you do what
your man says i have to ask you a very
specific question when you say follow
your man you're not married i'm not
married are you there's a big difference
between following your husband versus
following a boy it's very wise if you
had him thank you well you know because
i've been a husband for like a hot
minute but i've mostly been a good
boyfriend
shout out to the ladies out there
so when do you say all right i've only
been dating this guy for six months a
year you know i'm doing i'll tell you
i'm not following his lead i just met
this guy no no i'll tell you obviously
when you get married i can see that but
if you're dating when does it happen if
you want to have child children with
that guy or with a female there for you
you know because you know how your
children will be raised and that's how i
know that guy is for me and not for him
you know we are compatible with each
other we have the same views
we have the same
values as well like how we want to raise
our children and we have chosen
consciously to do that with one another
so how long did that take
well mine was you're not doing that in
week one you're not doing that in month
one well if you are that's problematic
for anyone out there if you're willing
to just sacrifice your entire life of
someone you've met for a week or a month
you know it took six to nine months to
draw out the paperwork right it all
comes about the italian restaurant it
all comes back to how clear you are and
what your goals are right like there is
a time and an age where you just know
like the older i get the more i think
about how i'm going to raise my children
although i don't have any children right
now this is what i have to worry about
because do i want to be bring children
in the world that we live in today well
it's questionable i don't know if i want
to bring children to these days now yeah
but it's not as horrible
thousands of years true but again
long enough you will right
again we're keeping distracted just by
doing different things and not focusing
on your main goal so right now i don't
have time to play around with you know
like just sleeping with guys or no i
don't have time doing that and my
partner doesn't have time doing that
either and why do i know that because we
share the same values and we share the
same goals respect and we are working
towards it so that's why it doesn't
really matter if you're married or not
again these are just labels if you
respect them and you know that you can
have children with that person then they
are for you
you